- You and I talked about anxiety.
How have you managed
this during quarantine?
'Cause everybody's kind
of managed it differently.
I've been writing a lot.
- That's awesome.
Yeah, it's interesting.
For me, you know, I've
always dealt with anxiety,
so going into lockdown, even
hypochondriac, which is great
for a pandemic when you're
a hypochondriac, girl!
And my old sort of techniques
of like meditation,
and the barn's always
amazing, but it just,
I was still having a lot of
anxiety, if I'm being honest.
And I started listening
to music as sort of,
when I couldn't drop into
meditation, I'd put on a record,
started listening to music,
and just wanting to listen all the time.
And I started thinking about
sort of the relationship
between anxiety, mental
health, and creativity,
and how healing is creative,
and creativity is healing.
And then that led into
this new podcast endeavor
about the power of music-
- It's called harmonics, right?
- [Beth] Yeah, it's called harmonics, and-
- [Kelly] And so what
exactly happens on it?
- So basically I talked to Glennon Doyle
who wrote "Untamed."
- I love!
- Girl!
- I'm a cheetah!
- So she's the first episode.
- Oh my gosh!
- And you can listen.
And she's incredible.
And Brandi Carlile, who-
- I love!
- [Beth] That duet you guys did-
- I've never been more vain.
I've never listened to
myself more than that duet.
- You two have the best
voices of all time,
and putting them together.
By the way, I played that
video over and over again.
I told Brandi, I was like-
- I'm like a million of the views.
- It's on repeat.
But I wanted to ask people
in the music industry,
but also people like Glennon Doyle, women,
how they handle this time, mental health,
what's happening in the world,
the division, in order
to bring people together,
promote love, and hopefully
provide some sort of healing.
And selfishly, I get
to ask people like you
all the questions I wanna
know about what do you do
for your mental health on a day
when you don't wanna get out of bed?
- This is an awesome podcast.
- I would love to have you on.
- I would love to come in.
You know who should have too,
another Glennon Doyle-type
of figure, is Brene Brown.
I love her.
- Her podcast is amazing.
- [Kelly] Yes, her TED talks.
- Her TED talks too, everything.
Yeah, I would love, I have a dream list.
This is season one.
I have like my dream list, but I-
- [Kelly] It's a really
smart and important thing.
- You know music and the power of healing.
I mean, and writing.
Have you been writing music or poetry?
- I literally don't know how
anybody goes through anything
horrible or big their life
without having an outlet
like I have with writing.
Like even if it doesn't get,
I was talking to Gwen the
other day on "The Voice."
And I was like,
we're both writing right
now for our next albums.
And it's like, even if no one
hears it, it's so therapeutic.
It's so good for you,
just that's your outlet.
- And it's almost like, you know,
whether you're religious
or not, or spiritual,
whatever you believe,
there's something about
that you're giving that
gift of your writing,
even if nobody ever sees it.
- And it's a little like Marie Kondo, too.
You're letting it go.
Like, thank you for the
experience; I'm done.
- Yeah, totally.
And I'm terrified for this
podcast because I'm usually
like the girl twerking
upside down on television,
and like falling down the stairs.
That's me, and everybody knows it.
- There's room for all of it, Beth.
- But I realize that,
like, if I expect my guests
to come on and not talk about, you know,
not just the classic sort
of interview questions,
if I want them to get vulnerable
and honest, then I had to.
And so I revealed some stuff,
and talked really deeply
about my mental health.
But then hearing like that
other musicians that I admire
have panic attacks
before they go on stage.
- Oh my gosh, especially musicians.
- Yes, we'll talk through it.
Brandi and I talked about when
she sang for Joni Mitchell,
and how, you know, turning blue.
- I just started sweating
for her right now.
Wow.
- But if she can get through
that, I can get there.
You know, there's something
about coming together
and speaking about mental health
openly, which for so long,
especially as women, we're
like, I can toughen up.
You know, I'm gonna
take care of my family,
I'm going to take care
of everybody around me.
- "Untamed," it's all in that book.
- [Beth] "Untamed"; cheetah.
- I know.
- So yeah, it's been amazingly
healing selfishly for me,
but also I hope it helps other people.